Wir haben ein gigantisches Plastikmüll-Problem
auf unsere Erde. Und es ist Zeit, das wir
etwas tun! Und zwar wir alle und es ist ehrlich
gesagt supereinfach. Plastik ist mittlerweile
überall: In unseren Körpern, am Straßenrand,
in den Wäldern und in den Tiefen des Ozeans.
Doch es gibt neue Ideen, um die riesigen Plastikberge
zukünftig zu vermeiden. Biokunststoff, der
im besten Fall einfach verrottet wie Laub.
Und das Beste daran: Mittlerweile ist es möglich,
einen Biokunststoff aus kompostierbaren Abfällen
herzustellen. Und wie wir alle aktiv weren
könne, das am Ende des Videso: Clixoom Science
& Fiction, Hier gibt es täglich spannende
Wissenschaftsvideos, abonniert den Kanal nur
dann verpasst ihr nichts Los geht’s
herzlich willkommen! Es gibt wohl kaum etwas,
was so praktisch ist wie Plastik: Es ist billig,
es hält ewig und man kann es eigentlich in
jedem Bereich einsetzen. Und genau deswegen
gehen wir wohl so verschwenderisch damit um.
250 Millionen Tonnen Plastik pro Jahr produzieren
wir weltweit - alleine in Deutschland entstehen
14 Millionen Tonnen Plastik-Verpackungen pro
Jahr. Viel davon schwimmt im Meer rum - ekelhaft,
tödlich für Tiere und dann als Mikroplastik
mit zahlreichen Schadstoffen dann am Ende
wieder bei uns in der Nahrung. Und in der
Luft landet es auch und dann im Essen. Es
ist wirklich schlimm. Das haben sich auch
die beiden Brüder Dane und Jeff Anderson
beim Surfen gedacht und ihre Firma namens
“Full Cycle Bioplastics” gegründet. Damit
wollen die beiden Abwasser-Ingenieure dem
gigantischen Plastikproblem unsere Erde den
Kampf ansagen - und gleichzeitig vielleicht
auch unser Leben revolutionieren. Was sie
dafür brauchen ist in aller erster Linie
organischer Abfall. Also beispielsweise Essensreste,
Müll aus dem landwirtschaftlichen Bereich
oder auch Kartons, die dann kompostiert werden.
Und zwar in einer eigens von ihnen entwickelten
Kompostieranlage. Darin laufen chemische Prozesse
ab und am Ende gibt es dann ein Abwasser,
das sehr viele Fettsäuren enthält. Durch
den Einsatz von Bakterien werden dann genau
diese Fettsäuren in Polyhydroxyfettsäuren
- sogenanntes “Mikro-Fett” - verwandelt.
Das ist eine zähe und milchige Masse, die
man dann zu Verpackungen pressen kann. Das
Tolle an diesem Konzept: Anders als andere
Hersteller werden hierbei keine extra Chemikalien
oder extra gezüchteten Pflanzen benötigt.
Und wenn die produzierten Produkte nicht mehr
gebraucht werden, nimmt ihre Firma sie zurück,
um wiederum neues Bioplastik daraus herzustellen.
Doch selbst, wenn es in der Landschaft oder
im Wasser landet, ist es dort noch lange nicht
so gefährlich und schädlich wie das konventionell
hergestellte Plastik. Denn nach Angaben der
Anderson-Brüder verrottet es einfach auf
natürlich Art und Weise - vergleichbar mit
Laub. WOW! Die beiden Anderson-Brüder haben
für diese innovative Idee schon viele Preise
abgeräumt und sie sind nicht die einzigen,
die das Plastikproblem der Welt auf solch
eine Art und Weise angehen wollen. Der Markt
ums Bioplastik ist hart umkämpft und die
Wachstumsraten weltweit sind gut. Biokunststoffe
sind schon aus vielen verschiedenen Materialien,
wie Stärke oder Zucker beispielsweise, produziert
worden. Doch mit ernüchternden Ergebnissen,
sagt beispielsweise das Umweltbundesamt. Denn
die Prozesse brauchen viel Energie, Wasser
oder doch viel zu viel Chemie. Das Fazit:
Bioplastik ist nicht gleich Bioplastik - der
Begriff “biologisch” bedeutet in diesem
Zusammenhang nicht automatisch, dass das hergestellte
Material auch biologisch abbaubar ist oder
auch ansonsten umweltfreundlich. Anders bei
dem Bioplastik des Anderson-Systems: Ihr Verfahren
seoi CO2-neutral, brauche wenig Energie und
Wasser. Kohlendioxid wird bei ihrem Kompostiersystem
zunächst sogar gebunden - wenn die Produkte
dann später kompostiert werden, wird es allerdings
wieder freigesetzt. Trotzdem: Der Prozess
setzt kein zusätzliches CO2 frei. Doch was
genau ist das Problem: Warum sind dann nicht
schon längst alle Plastik-Gegenstände dieser
Welt abgeschafft worden? Die Anderson-Brüder
sagen dazu realistischerweise, dass man bei
Dingen, die sehr lange Zeit überdauern sollten,
nicht mit Kompost arbeiten sollte. Ein Handy
oder Tablet aus Biokunststoff wird es also
erst mal nicht geben...Dafür aber vielleicht
unzählige andere Dinge, die eben nur einmal
verwendet werden: Tüten, Einweggeschirr oder
Verpackungen. Damit sich das aber wirklich
komplett durchsetzen kann, müssen solche
Konzepte, Bioplastik herzustellen, deutlich
günstiger werden. Denn nur dann kann mit
der konventionellen Plastikindustrie mitgehalten
werden. Doch die Chancen stehen gut, denn
der einzige Rohstoff, der gebraucht wird,
ist Abfall. Im überfluss vorhanden und zudem
kostenlos… Trotzdem: Bisher liegt der Umsatz
von Bioplastik in Deutschland, wie in den
meisten anderen Ländern dieser Welt, bei
gerade einmal knapp zwei Prozent. Doch die
Zahlen steigen! Das Labor der Anderson-Brüder
wird auch gerade erst noch fertig gebaut,
bisher wird nur ein Kilo “Mikrofett” pro
Tag produziert. Aber nicht nur in den USA,
sondern auch in Deutschland wird an solchen
Konzepten getüftelt. Beispielsweise hat sich
auch die Firma “Bio-Lutions” aus Hamburg
auf die Produktion von Bioplastik spezialisiert;
doch das Verfahren dazu ist anders. Die produzierten
Verpackungen bestehen aus faserhaltigen Pflanzenabfall.
Die Verpackungen von Gemüse und Obst beispielsweise
also bestehen letztendlich aus Bananenstämmen,
Tomatenstängeln oder Zuckerrohrblättern.
Werden sie entsorgt, verrotten sie so wie
Laub. Dieser sogenannte Faserguss, so heißt
das Verfahren, funktioniert auch hier ohne
zusätzliche Chemie. Konkret werden die Pflanzenreste
hierbei zu Nano- und Mikrofasern zerkleinert.
Wird Wasser hinzugefügt, entsteht ein Faserbrei,
der dann in verschiedene Formen gepresst werden
kann. Die Pilotfabrik dazu steht in Indien,
denn dort ist das Plastikproblem noch größer
als in Deutschland. Pro Monat entsteht derzeit
knapp eine Tonne Bioplastik. Bevor das ganze
Konzept marktreif ist, kann schon jetzt jeder
von uns etwas gegen die gigantische Menge
an Plastikmüll tun: Alles, was öfter benutzt
werden kann, ist umweltfreundlich: Also Mehrwegtaschen
wie ein Stoffbeutel oder ein Rucksack statt
Einwegtüten! Und wir können auch einfach
Produkte kaufen, die in Papier verpackt werden
oder Produkte, die lose verkauft werden in
Dosen abfüllen. Und, und, und. Ich werde
jetzt ganz konkret damit anfangen. Und ihr
könnt mitmachen. Auf Instagram habe ich den
Account “Getridofplastics” Werde plastik
los auf deutsch. und da sammle ich alles,
was es ohne Plastikverpackung gibt. Waschpulver
habe ich zum Beispiel gefunden oder es gibt
Seife als Haarshampoo in Papier verpackt.
Hier draufklicken. Und schickt mir dort eure
Ideen mit Fotos. Ich veröffentliche sie dann.
Ich freue mich auf eure Vorschläge. Bis dann,
bleibt dran!